hello everyone and welcome back to
Paul's harbur today is the long
anticipated launch of Intel's arc a580
graphics card the middle child in the
arc lineup That was announced more than
a year ago has finally come to market
the big question about it was the price
since it's not that far cut down from
the arc a750 and that price is
$180 it's slightly more than I was
hoping for I was thinking maybe 150 to
170 but we're going to see today if that
price is worth it because I'm going to
be testing the ark a580 specifically the
azrock Challenger OC model right here
against its nearest competition from AMD
Radeon that's the RX 7600 as well as
nvidia's RTX
3050 excellent today's video is brought
to you by Micro Center this is one of my
favorite places to buy PC parts so if
you're building or upgrading your PC I
highly recommend making your way down to
one of their 25 retail stores in the US
they have consistently competitive
prices and an excellent selection of PC
hardware and other Tech goodies and they
have a custom p PC Builder on the Micro
Center website use it to spec out your
rig and it will show you Parts in store
at your nearest location while ensuring
compatibility then you can pick up in
store or have their Pros assemble it for
you so click the sponsor Link in the
description to find a Micro Center near
you so let me start by explaining why I
was a bit intrigued when Intel told me
they were actually going to launch the
ark a580 I like budget builds because I
like introducing newcomers to PC gaming
and more recently the middle of the row
build that I've been pitching to people
is well over $1,000 around 1,200 bucks
for my recent builds and that is a very
solid build but not everyone has that
amount of money the build that I'm
pitching today along with the ark a580
is much less than that it's actually
less than $700 and in fact I threw
together a quick parts list over on PC
part picker with the CPU that I'm
testing with today which is the 5600x as
well as a b550 motherboard and 32 gigs
of ddr4 3600 RAM and the total as of
right now is actually about
$662 granted there are some upgrades you
can make here like going with a 2 TB
nvme SSD Poss possibly upgrading your
case to one that has more fans or going
with a higher wattage power supply if
you intend to upgrade your graphics card
in the future but for a lot of people
who are just trying to get their toe in
the door with an entry level build this
is right up their alley and even though
it's last generation am4 platform for
AMD with a b550 chipset motherboard
there is still an upgrade path here
because the 5800 X 3D which is still one
of the top CPUs for gaming can also
upgrade right into that build too so I
had that build in mind when I set up my
testing today we're going to be testing
five games doing side by-side
comparisons with the $180 Arc a580 the
$220 Nvidia GeForce RTX 3050 and 220
bucks is about the cheapest you can find
one of these right now as well as the
AMD Radeon RX 7600 which currently goes
for about $240 for the cheapest one but
that does mean that for $60 less the ark
a580 is 25% less expensive than the 7600
and all these cards have an 8 gig vram
buffer let's take a look at their
specifications really quick I rattle off
a few more notes about my testing
procedures we're going to be testing at
1920 x 1080 as well as 2560 X 1440 even
though these cards are more recommended
for 1080 than 1440 I also tested with
extra features like Intel's XS amd's FSR
and nvidia's dlss turned off so we could
compare the raw performance between
these graphics cards versus what you
could expect with those features turned
on because there's a lot of them it
introduces a lot of variables to testing
but please keep in mind that with these
cards and all the I tested today you can
get higher frame rates than what I'm
showing you on screen either by lowering
the game settings from what I'm running
or by turning on features like xss dlss
and FSR which can get you higher frame
rates by using techniques like upscaling
also please note that I'm using my x570
test bed here which does have some
higher-end components like an EVGA x570
dark motherboard a 1600 wat Corsair
ax600 I power supply and some nice
high-end ssds however the components
that will impact gaming performance
which are the CPU are still the same as
in that sub $700 build which is the
5600x for the CPU and 32 gigs of ddr4
3600 speed memory all that said let's
get into the testing starting off with
cyberpunk 2077 and we're using the
latest patch that came out along with
Phantom Liberty we're running High
settings with dlss FSR and xcss turned
off cyberpunk doesn't always accept
those settings I had to do a couple
reruns and had to reset the game in
order to get the settings to stick but
at 1920 x 1080 the ark a580 was
outputting about 65 to 80 frames per
second averaging around 74 we can see
that the RTX 3050 is not keeping up it's
down in the 50 to 70 FPS range 58 FPS on
average and the RX 7600 is maintaining a
decent lead going up to about 80 to 110
frames per second or 92 FPS on average
if we change resolutions to 2560 by 1440
the frame rates are going to drop the
a580 is now in the 45 to 60 FPS range
about 51 FPS on average meanwhile the
RTX 3050 is really struggling down there
in the 30 to 40 FPS range 37 frames per
second average but the RX 7600 is still
holding up pretty well getting 70 to 90
FPS or 82 frames per second on average
so that's a pretty decent win for team
red right there our next title is Far
Cry 6 we're running High settings with
FSR turned off at 1920 x 1080 The Arc
a580 is at 90 to 105 frames per second
averaging about 99 FPS the RTX 3050 is
about 10% slower running 80 to 95 FPS s
for 87 frames per second average and the
RX 7600 is once again maintaining the
lead at 115 to 145 FPS it did bounce
around a little bit more but maintained
a 126 FPS average jumping to 2560 by
1440 the a580 is at about 65 to 85
frames per second 78 FPS average the RTX
3050 is staying above 60 FPS about 60 to
70 frames per second average of 63 and
the RX 7600 is up above 100 100 to 150
FPS 106 frames per second average next
we have dirt 5 running at high settings
Dynamic resolution is off FSR is off at
1920x 1080 the ark a580 is at about 95
to 110 frames per second averaging 103
the RTX 350 is 70 to 85 FPS so still a
decent step behind the a580 averaging 78
but the 7600 is still a decent Step
Ahead getting up to 120 to 145 FPS or
140 on average if we bump the resolution
up to 1440 the a580 is now at 70 to 90
FPS 86 average the RTX 350 is having a
hard time sticking to 60 FPS it's
between 50 and 65 but it did get 60 on
average and the RX 7600 is once again
maintaining a pretty good lead at 95 to
120 FPS or 108 on average here's Doom
maternal for some Vulcan testing note
that this is not a built-in Benchmark so
the test runs here are going to vary a
little bit more from run to run we are
running the ultra preset though which is
one step below nightmare with DLS s
turned off the a580 at 1920 x 1080 was
hitting 165 to 220 frames per second
averaging about 185 meanwhile the RTX
3050 was down in the 140 to 195 FPS
range 165 on average about 20 below the
ark a580 and again the RX 7600 is
maintaining about a 50 frames per second
lead fluctuating between 185 and 260 for
about 230 FPS on average again if we
increase the resolution to 2560 X 1440
the frame rates will drop but we're
still hitting 120 to 155 FPS with the
a580 about 135 on average the RTX 350 is
about 15 frames behind in the 95 to 145
frames per second range or 120 on
average and the RX 7600 maintaining lead
still 135 to 170 FPS or 155 on average
and our last game is Starfield a game
I'm happy to test cuz it's a new and
popular title however it did present a
few complications that I will explain as
we go through this I'm testing using the
medium preset with Dynamic resolution
and FSR turned off and Starfield
actually had an update yesterday on
October 9th to version 1.7.3 6 so I did
go back and rerun my tests with the
update because one of the patch notes is
improved stability for Intel Arc gpus so
here's my test run at 1920 x 1080 and by
the way I'm using capf frame X and Reva
tuner to show this overlay of the stats
on screen that you're looking at The RK
580 got about 26 to 34 frames per second
averaging around 30 so that was a decent
step behind the RTX 3050 which was
getting around 35 to 45 frames per
second averaging around 40 and then the
RX 7600 which was outputting some pretty
nice performance for this game 60 to 75
FPS about 69 frames per second on
average however there was a weird Quirk
with the game that I noticed because I
was going back and rerunning tests if I
open the game menu after I load my save
up it actually tanks the frame rate
dropping from say maybe 30 average at
1080 down to maybe 22 is it was was
pretty noticeable and it did that at
both resolutions so I contacted Intel to
let them know about the behavior and I
ran these tests with like a fresh load
so I wasn't getting that frame drop and
then there was one last wrench in my
testing which was that Intel dropped a
driver update at the very very last
minute about 14 hours before the Embargo
listed and the driver update had
specific improvements for Starfield like
up to 117% uplift at 1080p Ultra up to
149% uplift at 1440 high so switching
from the driver I used originally 4830
to the new driver 4887 resulted in this
at 1080p about 39 to 44 frames per
averaging about 42 however again at the
end of my run after I let it go for a
while so I could compare to the other
cards again I popped up the menu again
and I did see that frame drop still
happen so it doesn't seem like it's been
addressed with this particular driver
but I have let Intel know about it
dropped me down to about 29 FPS which is
better than before but still a decent
drop from the 42 average so let's switch
over to 25 60 x 1440 so here with the
older driver 4830 I was getting 24 to 29
FPS averaging about 27 that's compared
to the RTX 3050 which was a step faster
about 27 to 37 frames per second for
Team Green here with about 32 average
FPS and then the RX 7600 performing
quite nicely once again 50 to 65 FPS 56
on average I did test that menu switch
again and my frame rate dropped from
about 27 average down to 16 so that's
still happening here but then here
here's the run with the driver updated
version 4887 that upped my FPS from
about 27 average to about 34 average so
it's getting between 30 and 38 FPS and I
don't know if that math works out to
what Intel is claiming in terms of an
uplift here but it is a decent uplift so
I was glad I reran this test with the
updated driver and here was also perhaps
array of Hope is that when I opened up
the menu at the end of the run my frame
rate dropped to about 19 to 22 FPS but
then it kind of bounced back and
recovered whereas before I would have to
actually exit the game completely reload
and load up my save again in order to
recover my frame rate back to what it
was supposed to be so there's my side
by- side testing I did set this video up
a little bit differently than my typical
Benchmark Review videos but I am sort of
getting back into the swing of things
after taking roughly four or five months
off from doing this type of content that
said I do have one more metric to share
and that is the peak power draw for the
entire system across all the tests
between the Cards here is probably the
only area where the RTX 3050 shines it's
pretty good in terms of efficiency only
speaking at 261.5 watt meanwhile the r
7600 got up to just shy of 300 watts
298.15 a0 was a bit more power hungry
peing at 327.5 Watts so clearly if
efficiency is your thing at the expense
of all else the RTX 3050 is a decent
choice but I would say in comparison to
the performance that you get and
especially down in this budget range
where the difference of 30 to 60 watts
in terms of power draw isn't going to
make as much of a difference especially
compared to the $40 to $60 price
difference but I still wanted to point
out the relative lack of efficiency for
the a580 by comparison so now that we've
taken a look at the numbers and I know
this is not my typical full review but
that does give us a good idea of where
these cards stand what is the upshot
first off the RTX 3050 just looks really
silly there's a rumor that Nvidia might
be releasing an even lower powered
version of the RTX 3050 and I really
hope they don't I'm actually sad that
this card still sells because it's it's
just dumb it's a dumb graphics card I
don't like it I think it's maintained a
much higher price than it really
deserves and it's not like Nvidia can't
make faster graphics cards than this
they totally can and they totally do
it's just they price those much higher
if Nvidia wanted to compete down in the
sub $200 price range they easily could
at any time they could come out with an
RTX 4050 or they could lower the price
of the RTX 4060 something unprecedented
like that but many of us are holding out
hope that Intel's advances in the GPU
industry are going to encourage Nvidia
and maybe even amd2 to lower their
prices and get a little bit more
competitive especially for entry-level
Gamers the comparison with the RX 7600
is not quite as favorable because the RX
7600 does outperform the a580 however it
does so at a $60 price premium right now
which down in this budget range is a
significant dollar amount again 25% less
for the a580 than the 7600 overall at
least when it comes to my admittedly
limited testing the ark a580 is
definitely a reasonable card for the
price they are asking for it I would say
it would be even more compelling if the
price could drop by 10 or 20 or even $30
at 150 bucks the a580 would pretty much
smash anything in the sub $200 category
but even 180 bucks it is still a viable
option for people who are truly trying
to stick to a budget but if you're not
in that category it might be worth your
while to scrape together a few more
funds to upgrade to something like the
a750 or the RX 7600 so there it is the
Intel Arc a580 if you're interested in
my $660 to $670 build around this card
check the video description down below
note that there's not just the ASRock
challenger but there's a couple other
models coming out from Sparkle and I
believe gunar and if you didn't check
them out already I'm going to post links
to some other reviews of the ark a580
that have come out today because I know
there's going to be some other good ones
that test against other cards or that
even have like graphs and stuff like
that cuz graphs are fun to look at
sometimes too but thank you guys so much
for watching this video If you enjoyed
it hit the Thumbs Up Button check out my
store at paul.net if you'd like to buy
some merchandise Shirts Mugs pint
glasses and more subscribe to my channel
if you're not already for more coverage
of video cards and PC hardware and we'll
see you all in the next
video